si la parole jean françois lamour
monsieur le premier ministre la semaine
dernière monsieur le premier ministre
votre gouvernement s'est prononcé pour
le démantèlement d'areva c'était la
question précédente ce colosse aux pieds
d'argile qui accuse près de 5 milliards
de pertes pour 2014
résultat de plusieurs années des
errements stratégiques et de querelles
de personnes entretenue par la
précédente présidente madame lauvergeon
alors que l'on mentionne déjà l'entrée
possible d'investisseurs étrangers dans
le capital de la future filiale en
charge directeur d'edf
je souhaite vous interroger sur l'avenir
de la propulsion nucléaire militaire
quand vous savez areva par sa filiale
areva t 1 et maître d'oeuvre pour la
construction le maintien en conditions
opérationnelles des réacteurs qui équipe
à la fois les sous marins nucléaires
d'attaqué sous marin nucléaire lanceur
d'engins le porte avions charles de
gaulle et le centre des sels de
cadarache notre charles de gaulle et la
composante océanique de dissuasion c'est
un pan essentiel de notre souveraineté
qui repose à la fois sur areva t ha et
sur la direction des applications
militaires du cea de puces monsieur le
premier ministre
l'état doit s'engager à partir de 2020
dont la construction d'une nouvelle
génération de sous marins lanceurs
d'engins c'est donc dès aujourd'hui que
doit d'intervenir cet état stratège qui
et c'est moi qu'on fizir ne s'est pas
illustré dans sa gestion pour le moins
hasardeuse du nucléaire civil
alors ma question et de monsieur le
premier ministre pouvez vous tout
d'abord nous dire quelle est l'option
envisagée pour la reprise d'areva t as
qu eux on parle de ça on parle de dcns
ou encore d'une filiale dédiée d'edf et
plus généralement pouvez vous nous dire
nous présenter les dispositions que vous
comptez prendre pour garantir le savoir
faire l'indépendance de la propulsion
nucléaire militaire
à l'aube de ce grand meccano qui va
bouleverser la filière française
la parole est à monsieur manuel mal
qu'on ministre de l'économie de
l'industrie et du numérique
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
l'amour vous avez raison de rappeler la
crise que vit aujourd'hui la filière
nucléaire qui est largement le fruit
d'erreurs stratégiques et industriels
passé et de la transformation en
profondeur du marché nucléaire mondial
la décision qui a été annoncée le 3 juin
dernier n'a rien à voir avec un meccano
industriel quel qu'il soit où un mécano
actionnariale il s'agit de refonder en
profondeur la filière nucléaire pour ne
pas reproduire les errements du passé et
lui redonner de la cohérence à cet égard
durant le mois qui vient
le gouvernement s'emploie à définir avec
les deux acteurs que sont edf et areva
en lien avec le cea justement un accord
industriel et commercial qui permettent
de mieux organiser cette filière de
régler les problèmes commerciaux qui
existe entre les deux entreprises
avec la perspective d'un adossement
d'une filière réacteur qui a vocation
donc à être détenue majoritairement par
edf
l'ingénierie quant à elle sera détenue
dans une société conjointe elle aussi
majorité majoritairement détenue par edf
voilà la conception qui a été retenue
pour préserver l'ensemble des
compétences des savoir faire et le plus
haut niveau de sûreté dans tous les
styles
dans ce contexte la areva t ha dont vous
avez rappelé l'importance dans le
domaine de la propulsion nucléaire de la
composante océaniques de la dissuasion
nucléaire sera maintenu dans son
intégrée dans son intégrité pleine et
entière
areva t as n'est pas concerné par la
refonte de la filière nucléaire que
j'évoque areva t as restera donc sous
d'areva sans aucune interaction
supplémentaire avec edf est en lien
direct comme elle l'est aujourd'hui avec
le cea et avec dcns le gouvernement
veille bien entendu tout
particulièrement à tout un pas que cette
réorganisation pourrait avoir sur areva
t ha et je vous garantis que
l'indépendance et toutes les conditions
qui sont aujourd'hui préservée dans
areva t as le seront durablement ainsi
que tous les programmes sans paroles